big stage for people to announce video
games one of the biggest secret
publishers in the world of video games
is activation so let's talk about what
they may or may not be showing off let's
talk about what they may be showing our
first call of duty infinite warfare I'm
guessing we're gonna see that just
probably see it yeah I'm Eddie and I
were just talking about it and obviously
you know we've always got battlefield
versus ecology yeah and I think it's a
really funny just help sort of
disconnect between the people who make
games with people who play games right
you guys already talked about it like
how worried yeah that like you know the
historical setting is not something that
game is why she and then it was exactly
what game is one is yeah but i think you
know obviously they just really aware of
the fact that call of duty is doing
sci-fi and they've got the future and
it's interesting to me there is call of
duty fatigue which i think is
contributed to how much people are
hating on that that announcement and
that yeah and there is just like a
there's a mob these out for cod and
awaited oh they absolutely are but it's
kind of like the thing is at the end of
the day they can make a really great
game they have to take advantage of that
setting though yeah and they have to
take advantage of the stuff that EA is
afraid of which is you can do cool [ __ ]
with the future then there that
battlefield are not going to be able to
do don't get me wrong all the world war
one stuff is gonna be amazing that's
gonna be a really cool setting but you
know if if they get the right team
together if they have the right like
creative vision they can come up with
like a brand new combat mechanics and
all kinds of [ __ ] that's gonna be
awesome I mean contemporary war stories
were never good for the longest time and
then call it a default a mesh-like right
with the white people on us you can get
it done and speaking of that they have a
they've actually hired after the big
Exodus at infinity ward they hired some
naughty dog people who came in are going
to be writing the story which is you
know exciting to think about we don't
know how it's going to be executed yet
yeah but that's definitely one of the
things I'm looking forward to and then
just you know the battle space dogfights
I mean you've never been able to do that
really in call of duty which slice which
seems really exciting to and there's
going to be maps on different planets so
yeah if just says like as she said like
if you take advantage if you have like
zero g gunfights which are weird and
like yeah just like if you if you just
say like it's a first person shooter
with the trappings of space it's
probably not going to be
to be more than cod in space that's it
it needs to like really are in this
concept yeah how are sales going for
call of duty because like it's so hard
to tell right cuz welcome to be selling
we do out over here we're hearing that
there's this plateau and a dip in the
recent years is that the case it's
tricky because the black ops series is
typically their number one franchise
overall so I mean there's there's you
know peaks and valleys every time they
come out but you know Infinity Ward is
obviously one of the most you know one
of the most respected and they created
modern warfare obviously so you know
there are high hopes for this one
certainly and it's the first one you
know as of yet they haven't announced
support for last gen consoles too so we
don't know right if that could you know
free them up to do more things that you
know if they didn't have to think about
last gen two so fingers crossed right
yeah um let's jump into another big game
for them world of warcraft legion that's
the thing it's coming out that is a
thing anywhere players here ice play wow
I played wow a lot but you know not not
recently you know i usually get drawn
back when the expansions come out I
don't know if it'll be the case this
time but I'm definitely I mean I'm
looking forward to it there's there's a
chance that i'll go back i mean in terms
of subscriber numbers though every time
there is a dip right before every new
expansion comes out and right now they
are at a nine-year low so they really
need this one to you know a kick in and
really bring more people like yeah
everyone i know who plays well place it
in waves like why shake it up for a
month or two when Josh comes out mention
subscription is cancelled again when
they remember to cancel it exactly yeah
maybe they got to push off the movie I
don't know it's been getting weird
reviews at the moment yeah there's a
promotion going on to wear certain
theaters will give you the game and all
the expansions if you go buy a movie
ticket so that what was all of the
expansions all the expansions now we're
actually free as of like a couple weeks
ago yeah really yeah my name's Greg they
want me to go back in ya gotta be so
butthurt like bought them all in
anticipation when you think about like I
mean it's still obviously the number one
paid MMO on the market no one's Ivan
close yeah it's you know they're the
genre-defining MMO they've been out for
ten years but it is seems like we're at
a point of crossroads here yeah yeah and
let's talk about one of their more
successful new
Johnson to the world of multiplayer
gaming destiny rise of iron is a rumor
we have seen we've seen pretty decent
like screenshot images which are sorry I
guess media you know promotionally right
it's not actual gameplay and do you
think we're gonna see that this year I
mean presumably they've talked about how
they expect to fall off and bungee say
that whenever we release a new one of
these it gets small back on important
thing there's going to be an
announcement event this coming Thursday
where they're going to talk about it
we're going to talk about what's next
for destiny which the big you know the
obviously the point is to rise of iron
but whether or not I mean and they've
said that the rumor is that is going to
be larger more substantial than house of
wolves behind the preview expansion of
the dark below so there's there's a lot
riding on it though tuned cool I wonder
if that's paving the way for them to do
destiny to at e3 my original is that
it's too soon because they're gonna want
all the focus to be on there you know
massive latest expansion and people
picking that up not thinking about the
next game yeah for sure but the fact
that they're announcing it in advance
and we're probably going to hear a lot
about the next expansion on Thursday
they haven't said it's going to be the
next expansion but it's a good guess but
yeah I I wonder what they're gonna pull
out at e3 it seems like a strange time
to decide to talk about it yeah just
ahead of either there you're right
though there has to be a reason right
yeah that's the reason that that seems
like an odd reason because either they
not really gonna say anything so they
can say more 83 in which case why hold
it on Thursday right or they're doing it
so then they can do a little destiny to
teaser or something why don't they just
go well into it what if I'm Thursday
just sedans destiny for PC oh gosh yes
hey go I mean they have like Eric
Hirshberg the CEO of Activision
Publishing was in an interview and he
said you know destiny is a good fit on
paper for PC you know everything sets up
well it's just and I don't know why they
wouldn't do it I mean all the other
franchises are there no so it's weird
yeah it's only yeah it's one of these
things you kind of forget that oh yeah
like red bad yeah do you think it's such
an obvious fit so why wouldn't do it if
you say it enough you know it'll happen
yeah we're just like yeah we're saying
right that for a while
let's look at I mean looking at the rest
of activations ip's it is a big list of
ifs buts and maybes I mean I can't see
no Tony are getting dawn I'm curious it
to know about what might happen with
guitar hero rise they said sales have
fought like they were below what they
wanted which it like it's not
necessarily a death knell for because
maybe they had you know predicted too
high but at the same time I've been
playing the new guitar hero and the new
guitar is you know it quite a leap from
what it was and it's not as easy to get
into which I thought was the whole
appeal of guitar hero was that anybody
can pick up in the gladly living room
rock star but it's kind of tricky this
time it's also we grew up with like that
kind of guitar like Adam Easter and it's
just like getting used two buttons that
are next to each other and then down the
phrase like wow we too are we old dogs
with new tricks already gosh that's
awesome we're just old what about
Skylanders I mean disney infinity's
fallen by the wayside that that space
got real busy I gotta help I mean I
think it has to help right cuz like that
i mean what all the different players
are were in there that market just
didn't grow big enough to you know
accommodate them all and some something
had to give i guess it wasn't enough for
disney yeah do you think they're gonna
keep moment Skylanders they've announced
a new one coming this year the very last
one didn't perform as well as they
wanted you know Giants officially oh no
just super charges yeah John's a couple
years ago actually gone so there's a
number of you know I me and I was just
in a target retail store and they have
Chris waters I always say I hear him
like I know he's there and yet it still
surprises me ever and always got every
time Exxon o'clock but I I mean I sorry
I'm not counting that out I mean
obviously you know a randy is the big
Skyler span himself and he always talks
about how you know that franchise has
more appeal than maybe people are you
know talking about it i mean it's
something that I wouldn't bet against
yeah there you go well anything else you
can think of Activision wise Activision
is just gonna do Activision well they
don't have a booth at e3 this year which
is interested yeah and they've been said
you know elected to partner with Sony
for a call of duty whether or not it
shows up at their booth or you know
presumably it would be out there
stage show yeah on Monday all right well
we have to wait and see not too much
longer though tick-tock III is a common
make sure you check out gamespot for all
the latest III news throughout the week
you've also got too crazy stage shows
downstairs you got the coop stage with
our friends a screw attack and kind of
funny live and look at this lovely
picture just appearing on my Bobby
Kotick god I might it's my annual check
in with dr. Bobby looking forward to
that and yeah we've got a great States
your dance there is a wonderful trailer
Rob handling put together up on the site
and on YouTube as well i'm pretty sure
by this stage and then upstairs we were
doing game demos for three days straight
myself jess and Lucy are going to be man
on that one said I'll be great we've
always got a wonderful set of interviews
with various developers which should be
great to listen in to so make sure you
check that air thank you so much